well and josh fleming looking to keep
the win streak going three starts on the
season he is a perfect 3-0
15 in a third innings of work and that's
about what you can figure you're gonna
get out of him in that five to six
inning range alex at 3 11 6 homers 14
rbis
well he's already one of our favorites
and there is strike three call
he doesn't waste pitches he doesn't
waste time he goes out there
goes about in his business
[Applause]
martinez is out on strikes no runs a man
left ray's coming in to hit
it'll be mike kick him on the mound
making the start for the red hawks 14th
start of the season for boston his first
start since july of 2013.
that's right last time out of the
bullpen he got his first win in major
leagues and that
walk-off win against toronto another
finesse left-hander for the red sox
well here's margaux in the lead-off spot
a broken bat off the mound kick him with
the pickup throw to first and they
throw it by the first baseman doll back
down to second goes margot
and the rays have an instant scoring
opportunity
he made a heck of a play off the mount
sliding glove now a little trouble
getting it out but he makes a nice
strong throw and
that's the ball that's got to be caught
fastball running down and in and the
runner's stealing third to throw and
he's out but he was already in scoring
position marcel margot
and well margot tried to steal third and
was gunned down
delaney still delayed steal i've never
seen that before
josh fleming back to the hill he will
face the boston catcher
and a cut in a mess he went upstairs
and got him to cut her up and in
and the big swing by vasquez just not
able to get up to it and fleming
continues
to do really good work out there on the
mount
well here it comes and he got him boy
that
change up a dandy and you you could just
read
the body language of munoz in there
there's one on with two outs rafael
dever
devers drives this one right field side
if it stays fair it's gone two run home
run
for rafael devers he got it around the
right field pole in the red sox take a
two nothing lead
well he sat at home plate forever he had
to watch it he
he didn't know if it was fair foul too i
think he hit it over the foul bowl
i believe you're right and you know on
contact he knew
it had distance so mike kick him with
the lead now
one down here in the third austin
meadows who drew a walk with two outs
back in the first inning two and two
from kick him
swinging to miss strike three second out
here in the third as he gets meadows
i tell you what it's working got five
punch outs in two and two thirds innings
so hit by a pitcher's first time oh and
he gets heck up out of his chair with
the fastball on the sixth strike out of
the night
so here's hunter renfro to lead things
off for the raise in the bottom of the
fourth trying to get anything going
against
mike kick him there's a shot
way back into the deep part of center
and
gone home run for renfro
home run number seven well there's a
little something off the left-hander
and the raids are on the board for the
first time tonight
that ball stays flat doesn't have a
whole lot of cutting action to it at all
now here's lyle sending a fly ball into
center bradley jr goes back
jumps so that one is out of here
home run from brandon loud back-to-back
homers
back-to-back pitches renfro and now lau
and just like that this game is tied or
two
big shots to center if we go to the
fifth inning now tied at two
bobby dahlbach who struck out swinging
his first time up here's the pitch
and a swing to drive down the right
field line deep back it goes and it
is gone opposite field home run bobby
dahlbach
he hits his sixth he drives in his ninth
run and the red sox lead it three to two
dalback becomes the second player in
major league history
to homer in six of his first ten games
before he crushed
the deep right field he's over now in
five straight games that ties a red sox
record
the tying run at second netto slices one
down the left field line in a hurry as
munoz he can't get it
takes a bounce and goes up off the wall
around third and scoring easily is
margot and austin meadows into second
with an rbi double
this game is tied at three put two on
with only one out
for the red hot rafael devers tie game
here in the seventh
ground ball right side gets doing the
base hit
they'll send the runner around arroyo
coming home and
he'll get in there for the go ahead and
run red sox take a 4-3
lead third rbi of the night for devers
how about the night divers assad the
two-run home run is single now a single
to drive in a run
oh he's on fire right now we go to the
bottom of the ninth and matt barnes is
trying to save it ray's now
down to their last chance potential
tying run at third
and strike three called fastball
very top of the zone at 97.
a call third strike to end this game
this is another one not going to ray's
way